ついにこの日が来てしまったかとりあえず打ち上げの準備をしておこう
そうですそ女性今日暇山田から今からさーああちょっと卒業できることが確認するかの
撮影としたら今日ウチは見えないかもしれない金子だったじゃねぇ
大変ですね
怖いなぁ開けです
なるかはぁっはぁっあっていた今日は大学生の初めさそうですよジョイをこの時が来て
しまったな
僕は決して結果はどうだっていいんですようかやることやりました大学生活最後の
テストの計先の結果を今から見ます
も実は見れたんですけどベッドで静的確認するためのアカウントの id と
パスワード全部忘れちゃって学校に行ってね打ちパスワードと id をゲットしたん
だよ皆さんに言いました結果はさんの動画で言うと僕は言ったんで今から僕が大学を
卒業できるかどうかがわかりますなんかよく2ちゃんねるとかで俺見るからね
チャンネルこれ見たぞ2ちゃんねるでねチャンネルデビュー年経由地
java とか留年回もしてないイギリスに留学とかねそのでいう関係で1年遅れたん
ですけど留年は一度も捨てませんぷっ長さんとやることはやりましたからねできれば
このままストレートで耐えば留年したらしたで美味しい
いやおいしくない美味しいてないよで太陽一発で卒業論文がクリアしましたとで授業北
二つとってておるとなる語と英語のコミュニケーションや使ったその二つの成績が取れ
でバー単位が足りて卒業できるという感じでございます
本当に強いつは強化が4つあるんですけどすごい優秀な人の ss ランクマが良かっ
たよっていうえー何かよかったんじゃないっていう b ランク
まーた論じで許そう c ランク後はバッツ
この5種類があるんですけどもまぁ日かじゃなければとりあえず行けます全て足が
すべて帰宅はパスワードありますよリイシュー aa はいうゲーティング所あれ
大学にそんなバカ d 幽霊は uft イメーション
入れた山路だよ本気本気本気本気でこれ決まったよ本当にて安が増えてきた成績条項
あ待って待って本当になってまずで壊せ汗がて安いかっ
あは金降っ
成績情報で年別単位
スク待ってましてマテ待てマテ待てませんの問題も実家英語のコミュニケーションの
成績から見ていきましょう
結果です
よっしゃ
いやぁああああああ
よっしゃとりました
ん
ています
もうぜぇお疲れすぅお疲れさん卒業できるかどうかは確認してるんで
ひょっとしたら今日祭か欲しいんですよ入ってから有用
遊行感って言うようカードちゃんアーちゃん noosa ティックアタッカー神明
それとぴょんぴょん配置いきましょう
英語のヘッダー100点中85ぺんっ
ゲスまで行かなかったんですけど a ですよしよしよし
mature て次だと問題はさあ次でございますポルトガルとギリギリまで頑張って
覚えたんでポルトガルを確認していきましょーがんばって本当に頼む
うん
ん
2ヤッターにゃんっ
それだやったぁー
rar
あああああ
それでバーン
ファンては店舗本当に待ってマジで言ってんの100点中75点評価 b でござい
ました
てありがとうやっ
待って待ってなぜま一応これで音楽フェスとはしっかりとれってということが分かり
ました待って大事なんだここ柄でございます4つ僕は効くんじゃ大学生で単位はとって
卒業できると思ってたけど実は単位が足りなかったみたいなパターンがあると聞いたの
で俺の中で卒業できている今卒業要件
要件合計が必要単位が126を汚しと
車単四135方判126
卒業いやー
ああああああ
1手本的に来た人もおっしゃー
もう大学番でもいいやなんかこんな感じでですねでこっちが必要な単位数でこっちが僕
の取った単位てるんですけどもまぁ結構オーバーして全部取ったというわけでござい
ますなぁん
宣言した通り僕は行ってやりましたちょっとバック
なんかいうことねーなーなんだろうな
本当に大学生はっつあんだな長かった学生生活がこれでひとまず終わりこれから僕は神
様に映像関係でこう何かやっていければなと実は思っていまして人は梅雨チューバ
続けるんですけども
その先で何かコースたいことが3つかれればなと思って
造形の勉強とかもしたいなと実はこっそり思っておりますまあひとまずねいえチューブ
型の
いいですよ特に学生の皆さん
大変だと思いますがなぜ僕がこんなに卒業に執着心があるのかといいますと
誰かにお金を大家から払って
危ないおや辛いぞいて通っているわけでございます10月ないちゃんからすっごいや
どれ
魚中学も高校もね大学も学校に行けてるのは全て親のおかげです
親から高いお金を出してもらって行かせてもらっている学校だったんでちゃんと卒業
するのが一つの毛ずメイクだと思いまして頑張らせていただきました
よくに学校
やめるって人をよく聞くんですけど
それはそれで良いと思いますたぶんルールで辛いこととかね
やりたいこととか考えた結果がそれに行ったんでまぁそれもそれでいいと思うんです
けど僕は
まあ親が頑張って
これは頑張って働いたお金で行かせていただいていると思ってるんでもう何が何でも
絶対卒業してやろうと思っててがそれがも約束だったんですよ
何が気に入るね絶対卒業するっていう約束で僕は在学に行ったんでまぁ国家を床として
の約束を守れたのかなと思いますこれからカリスマにユーチューバーさせようなことに
よっていければいいなと思っております